This is from Destiny's attorneys. This is filed in connection
with her motion for preliminary injunction. Plaintiff moves to
file under seal. Your client also threatened physical harm to
other individuals that have spoken out against him and in support
of the plaintiff. For Jtock and Queen, I if I could, I'd show
up to their house and do it. I do want someone to J though or
Lav or Mr. Girl or Queen. All those people can go die. Damn,
that don't sound so cute on paper. No, it doesn't. And it's I
don't know how. So, this gets replied to. I wonder if there's
any comment on this at all. You wouldn't do you are a pathetic
Destiny's kind of arguing to these people. Hey, I shouldn't have
to I these shouldn't be like filed right away without, you know,
the motion to seal being finished. There's like there's some
procedural thing here, but there's like a couple different things
to talk about. So here, what do we got? Document 72. This is
the initial filing. Okay, so this is Oh, hold on. What is this
called? This is explicitly response and opposition to motion.
Response in opposition to plaintiff's motion for leave to file
declarations under seal filed by Steven Banell's attorneys. Replies
due by May 16th. Okay. All right. You guys keep saying things
to like troll Kelly. I do not like it. I do not like it. I do
not like it. Please stop. Please stop. Okay. So, this is from
Destiny's attorneys. This is filed in connection with her motion
for preliminary injunction. Plaintiff moves to file under seal.
Huh? You can't see anything? Uh, no. I didn't see any trolling.
But also, sorry. I'm just trying to fix there's like I was just
trying to fix the OBS thing. Sorry. I don't know if this is going
to work, but I I've got it open. I just skipped the version and
hopefully it works. I'm not sure. Someone sends a dono. Then
we'll be able to check. Soap Society says, "Have they ruled out
Aaylor's Danlas?" Kelly, they've given me a So, they do a capillaroscopy
of your fingernails to check for vascular instability with a
damos, which they have done. Although that's not Are you super
flexible, Kelly? I'm not. So, it's not one one of the ones I'm
worried about, but there is a vascular version of it was down.
Okay. Imagine where your vascular system is stretchy. Doesn't
sound good, does it? Uh, no. Doesn't sound good. Okay. Going
again. In connection with her motion for preliminary injunction.
Plaintiff moves to file under seal three anonymous declarations.
Plaintiff's motion should be denied for three reasons. Plaintiff
failed to meet and confer prior to filing her motion. So, if
we remember, that was something that uh the judge asked them
to do was to stop filing motions. Although, I don't know if that
necessarily requires the uh like if this required the judge to
okay something, then maybe it'll it'll depend on how the judge
rules this, right? So, this is all going to come down to when
they filed
fear. Okay, $10. Hope you feel better. Sophia donated to say,
"Hope you feel better."
Yeah, I got it cuz it worked. Thank you. So this is all to do
with um Destiny or sorry Pixie's team filing these affidavit
as redacted filings. Okay. So under penalty of perjury of blank
blank this is the person's full name. Okay. So the issue here
is Destiny's team says we need the identities of these people.
We want the identities of these people and we think unredacted
copies should be filed um in the meantime or these should be
stricken from the record. So basically the argument will basically
be is Destiny trying to push them to file unredacted copies to
get these people to recant or are they, you know, filing normal
procedures under like normally under court procedures? And I
think I think Pixie's legal team has an like an argument for
not wanting to file these unredacted or give these to the the
defendant unredacted because basically Destiny's team has twice
now taken private deliberations in in uh like conference and
made them public. SNC will say, "Well, you didn't talk to us
about this." And they want the the identities of the people who
have filed these, right? So, it's some argument between is this
an intimidation tactic? Yes. Or is this um like what is this?
Destiny knows who these people are 100% because obviously beginning
in late May 2024, our conversations progressively became more
personal. We began exchanging private like all of these have
like timelines for when they when they started talking to him,
stopped talking to him, exactly what their their correspondence
was for all these things, right? So, there's no reason Destiny
wouldn't know who these people are. He would have records of
who these people are. Literally, that's his testimony is I've
saved all of these records. I have records of all these people.
Can we zoom in a bit more, please? Uh, sure. Thank you. Sure.
Sure. So, yeah. So, basically, it's these ones that they want
um unredacted copies of these. I believe they argue for unredacted
copies of these filed, but I didn't do a deep read through of
these things. So, we'll we'll see exactly what they say. So the
reasoning for this is u plaintiff uh plaintiff Pixie Pixie's
legal team failed to meet and confer prior to filing her motion.
Plaintiff refuses to identify the names of the declarance to
defendant Benell's council. And three, the federal rule and statute
upon which plaintiff relies are not applicable here. Um okay.
I think what Pixie's team should do is they should talk about
how Destiny was reaching out to a bunch of people about Abby
before she'd even before it was even filed regardless of how
it was filed, redacted or not. Right. That's a little concerning
I would say. But anyway, at 7:59 p.m. EDT on Friday, May 2nd,
2025, Plaintiff's Council emailed the undersigned stating, "Pursuant
to local rule 7.1, we are meeting and conferring on the following
motions. Motion to file under seal certain documents and it and
its proposed order. Motion for leave to exceed page limit on
reply memorandum. The documents to be filed under seal are certain
statements by witnesses which purpose is to keep uh who which
whose purpose? Which purpose? I whose purpose, right? I don't
know how you'd say this in in plural. Which purpose is to keep
their names out of the public? You and your client will know
their identities. I apologize for not reaching out before it's
been an intense week. Okay, so they're basically saying, "Hey,
we're we're filing these things." Um, the way I see this is they're
saying, "Okay, we don't know exactly how this is going to work.
We're filing it redacted because we don't want the identities
to be exposed publicly, and now we're meeting in conference to
discuss the exact way we're going to pursue this." Okay. Uh,
supplementary Breler declaration a emphasis added at 11:40 p.m.
on May 2nd. Plaintiff filed her motion for leave to file declarations
under seal ECF number 48. At 12:05 a.m. EDT on Saturday, May
3rd, after the deadline to file her reply papers, plaintiff filed
the declarations in redacted form. ECF 424 42 or 492 494 495.
At 10 a.m. PDT on May 3rd. 10 a.m. PDT on May 3rd. Banell's council
requested unredacted copies of plaintiff's filings. Supple supplementary
Breler declaration declaration exhibit B. Despite so we'll go
through these as well. Despite repeated requests, plaintiff refused
to reveal to Benell the names of her defendants or declarants.
Sorry. The local rule requires a filer filing a redacted exhibit
to contemporaneously serve a version of the exhibit upon all
council that is either unredacted or that contains only the the
those redactions authorized in connection with producing a document
to another party in
Uh so this has not been discovered yet. This has not been like
determined yet. So I think what they're arguing is basically
the judge hadn't agreed to file things under seal and you're
filing as if they'd agreed to file under seal. I think that's
what he's basically arguing here to date. This is local
5.4F1A. To date, plaintiff has not complied. Supplementary declaration
paragraph 5. Instead, plaintiff argues that because she elected
to file redacted declarations under rule local rule 5.3b1, she
is somehow excused from the requirement of subse subsection F
of the local rule and contends that Banell has no right to receive
the unredacted documents at this time. I think I don't know if
I don't know if that's the argument. We'll see. So, plaintiff
provides no support for this contention. At minimum, Banell should
be permitted to know the identities of the purported witnesses
who are providing testimony against him. Again, he knows the
identities. He's literally checked in on Abby with all of his
friends, right? Like, he's literally gone directly to his friends
to check in on these things. Florida Sunshine Law wouldn't have
jurisdiction here. This is federal court. Oh, interesting. Well,
I think I think a lot of people think the local rules should
apply here. I actually think Pixie's team is support is citing
the local rules as well. So, that's interesting. Further plaintiffs
reliance on rule rule 26 C1 of the federal rules of civil procedure
and 15 USC6851 is entirely misplaced and those authorities have
no bearing on her motion to file under seal. Rule 26 pertains
to seeking a protective order in connection with discovery. Federal
rules of civil procedure 26 C1. The code the code section provides
that the court may grant injunctive relief maintaining the confidentiality
of a plaintiff under a pseudonym 15 USC 6851 B3 uh B3B. Neither
is applicable here. For the foregoing reasons, Banell request
that the court deny plaintiff's motion to file under seal and
order the plaintiff to file unredacted versions of declarations
or strike them from the record. I think there's obviously another
thing here where they could say, "Hey, we wanted to file these
things because we didn't know if they need to be filed in time
for the motion." Like basically, we were having issues filing.
We we were trying to file last second and we wanted these filed
because we weren't sure. And we figured the safest way to do
that because we're filing under seal is to file the redacted
copies and then let you make your decision.
local rules are the federal district local rules. Oh, I see.
Okay. So, that's their their argument is basically like you don't
have any ability to do this unless the judge makes a ruling.
So, I think probably it seems like this is again them saying
it seems like Pixie's team hadn't filed the motion to or hadn't
made the motion to file under seal and then they had all of these
statements and they filed it all at the last second as the as
the deadline was approaching, right? They didn't want to miss
the deadline. Okay. And this is one of the witness statements.
So, I want to go now to um Brett Ller provided this in relation.
So, this is his declaration. Um funny enough, Destiny argued
he's like, "Wait, can lawyers just do this? They can just file
affidavit." And then uh his lawyer did one literally within a
week. Good times. Yeah, obviously they can, bro.
What's that? What's that, Kelly? Oh, zoom in. I got it. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. I got it. I didn't hear you, but I did it anyway.
I Andrew B. Breler declare pursuant to 28 USC 1746 as follows.
I am an attorney admitted to a practice pro. Oh, eports Batman,
if you want to come on, you can come on so we can review this
stuff if you're interested. Um, hop in the waiting room of that
other Discord if you want to hop on. Up to you, though. Uh, I
am an attorney. There he is. Oh, cool. What's up?
So, uh, I'm going to link you the, uh, local rules and they specifically
outline how to file, uh, disposal of materials under, uh, sealed.
Well, this specific rule is 5.4. for filings under seal disposal
of sealed materials. Yeah, the way I see it is they probably
or the way I read that the way I read it was um that probably
they need to file a motion to seal and talk to the judge and
then the judge could make a determination, right? Yeah. Ideally,
that's how you want to do it. And and under federal rules, like
the general federal rules, not the specific local rules, that's
generally how you would follow it under rule 26, which is kind
of their contention. But if as I understand it with regards to
the local rules, there is an allowance for this. Um there there
is an allowance for this. There is a limited allowance for this.
I'll Okay, let me look through the rules real quick and I'll
find you the specific section. Uh but Caiba already linked to
it was pretty on top of things. So let me go ahead and read through
the local rules real quick. Oh, sure. I'm going to read Breler's
declaration here. Uh I, Andrew B. Threatler declare pursuant
to 28 USC 1746 as follows. I think this is the you don't have
to um I think it's under penalty of perjury, right? It's probably
that one again. I am an at maybe not. I actually literally don't
know. Hold on. I assume that's what it is. But unsworn declarations
under penalty. It is. Thank god. Okay. I am an attorney admitted
to practice Brohawk Viche in the above captioned action. I am
a partner at the law firm Burke Bretler LLP in West Hollywood,
California along with our local council at Bills and uh Sberg
Bay and Axelrod LLP. We we represent defendant Steven Kanel II.
I have personal knowledge of the matters contained herein and
if called to testify called upon to testify could offer competent
testimony there too. I submit this supplemental declaration declaration
in connection with Benell's opposition to plaintiff's motion
to file under seal ECF number 48. Three anonymous declarations
ECF numbers 492 494 495 plaintiff filed in support for her motion
for preliminary injunction ECF number 21. Uh, attached here to
as exhibit A is a true and correct copy of emails I received
from plaintiffs council on May 2nd, 2025. Attached here to as
exhibit B is a true and correct copy of my email exchange with
plaintiffs council from May 3rd to May 5th, 2025. Despite my
repeated requests, today plaintiff's council could have council
have refused to identify the declarance whose declarations were
filed in redacted form. I declare under penalty of perjury that
the foregoing is shrink executed on May 9th, 2025. So he's saying
that um maybe I I think the other argument they have here esports
Batman and as you read this you can um you can see I think they
are arguing that they should be provided in any case with the
identities of these people directly right like the the defense
should be provided with the identities of these people generally
speaking yes but uh this is I put it in chat which is that if
prior to the issuance of a ruling on the motion to file under
seal the moving party elects or is required to publicly file
a pleading motion memoran random or other document that attaches
or reveals the content of the proposed sealed material, then
the moving party must redact from the public filings all content
that is subject to the motion to file under seal. Yeah, that
would that would do it. And then if the court grants the motion
to file under seal, then the moving party shall file any pleading
motion, memorandum or other document that has been authorized
to uh be filed under seal via CM ECF using events specifically
earmarked for sealed civil filings. But if a redacted filing
previously has been made or is accompanied the sealed filing
then the material is being filed under seal shall be uh filed
as attached to notice of sealed filing which is which shall be
uh filed via
CM/ecf. The moving party must complete any required service of
the sealed filing or notice of sealed filing uh conventionally
indicating the corresponding docket number of the sealed file
filing or notice of sealed filing. though that's my understanding
is they did provide notice and if I'm reading the rule correctly
which I may or may not I you know I'm not a Florida attorney
who practices in the federal courts of Miami. It allows you to
kind of preemptively file it if you have to and then the court
will make a decision and then you can either refile it or you
can without the seal or you can that makes total sense to me
where they had a deadline for their reply to the motion to oppose
the motion to whatever, right? They were filing under a deadline.
They had to file and they said, "Okay, we need to because a part
of our filing is a motion to seal. We're filing the redacted
pieces and then we can talk to the judge about the motion to
seal. Yep. Okay. And then the the chief um the chief rebuttal
from Breler here, the first one, I assume these are in order
of strength, is plaintiff failed to meet and confer prior to
filing her motion. Now, I think Pixie's team should say, "Okay,
first you released our private um pre-trial negotiations over
settlement. You released those in order to win a PR battle. And
then after we discussed um basically, hey, Pixie didn't want
you after we discussed this preliminary injunction stuff, basically
Pixie said, okay, I'll take down my Substack post if you'll take
down your videos, like exposing my DMs, right? And then Destiny
leaked that publicly on his stream. Pixie didn't leak that. Destiny
leaked that publicly on his stream. I think they have a strong
argument for our conferences are actually just being used to
wage PR war and we don't trust this party at all. In fact, we
we basically don't even trust them to have these names. No. Yeah.
Not to mention that the very facet of the conferences being pre-trial
and being uh more or less secretive is being completely blown
out of the water by you know one of the parties completely leaking
everything in real time or just thereafter their occurrence.
So yeah I I can understand the argument from Pixie side. But
what is his argument going to be like? Your honor, I goon too
hard and I spoke to too many women. Yeah. To be clear, Pixie
is the moving party for this preliminary who these people are
and the moving party for filing these as well. Obviously, he
knows who these people are, but what he wants is their legal
identity so he can go around and dox them and like intimidate
and humiliate them because why the else would he need a legal
information? I mean, presumably as far as like Abby is concerned,
he has that. So then he knows that. So what is he by giving him
unsealed versions of this? What is he receiving that he doesn't
already have? There's there's an argument to be made there. It
might be one of the other two anonymous people that has probably
it. That's I want to read this and I want to see how reasonable
it is that you wouldn't know given the timeline who this person
is. So this this is one of the people. Um I think this is Hold
on. Is this this is this should be witness a I believe. I'm over
18 years of age. Blah blah blah blah. Beginning on May 25th,
2024, I began exchanging messages with Destiny on Instagram and
subsequently on Discord, where I engaged with him as a fan. Shortly
thereafter, beginning in late May 2024, our conversation progressed
and became more personal, began exchanging private content with
one another graphic content of himself alone, as well as graphics
content depicting himself and other individuals engaging in facts.
Destiny shared some of these videos with me directly via Discord
messages, but the majority of them were shared through a Google
Drive link, which he sent me via Discord for the first time on
or about early June 2024. The graphics content that he shared
with me was mostly digital videos, although there were some digital
photographs as well. I ceased contact with Destiny on or about
November 5th, 2024. Subsequently became aware of the allegations
that there had been online leaks of Destiny engaging in acts
with individuals. On or about January 21st, I became aware of
Jane Do's post. this one. Maybe he It's possible he doesn't know
who this is. That he started a relationship with somebody on
Discord in May 2024 and that it progressed quickly. Maybe that
is not enough for him. Okay. Although I had access to messages
between myself and Destiny at that point on January 21st. Okay.
So this basically this is what I was looking for is he should
have access within his logs that he saved. So they say although
I had access to messages between myself and Destiny at that point
January 21st. Sometime afterward, I discovered that Destiny had
deleted messages between me and him on Discord and subsequently
discovered that I no longer had access to the Google Drive containing
the graphics content which appeared to be deleted. So again,
he should have logs of this anyway, right? Yep. Yeah. Okay. Yep.
All right. I'm going to hop out, but I if you check your DMs,
I linked you to the portion of the local rules that I read earlier
in case you want to go over them later on or if you wanted to
read up on them further. Okay, neat. All right, take it easy.
Talk to you later. See you. Bye. Okay, so this is uh this is
the other this would be witness B I think. Yeah, this should
be witness B. So on or about April 20, 2022, I reached out to
defendant Steven K. Benell Destiny via Twitter. Shortly thereafter,
we arranged to get together in blank where we began a relationship.
Thereafter, Destiny and I remained in contact and I also became
friendly with his wife at the time, Molina Garansson. At some
point, Destiny asked me if I was comfortable with him sharing
videos/p pictures of content involving himself as well as his
himself and his wife. I told him that I did consent to his sharing
these videos with me. Uh thereafter, we began sharing pictures
and videos of the nature with one another. Most of the other
most of the videos that Destiny sent were of him alone. However,
at least one of these videos included himself and his wife. On
or about mid to late April 2023, Destiny invited me to blank
where he and was staying briefly. Well, so again, where were
you in April 2023 and who did you invite to there? It's like
you you literally know who this is, right? Your honor, I goed
too hard in April of 2023. I don't know who that was. Uh Destiny
invited me to blank where he was staying briefly. While at blank,
Destiny recorded himself and I engaging in acts. The recordings
were made with my consent and I authorized Destiny to share these
record the recordings with his wife exclusively. I did not authorize
Destiny to share these recordings with anyone else or to otherwise
make them public. Thereafter, I continued to communicate with
Destiny online. In late November 2024, I was harassed by multiple
individuals while on Discord who informed me that a video involving
Destiny and myself had leaked online. After confirming this that
this was was the case, I confronted Destiny who told me that
he was sorry that any videos involving myself had leaked because
of him. Destiny also told me that he had only shared the this
content with a single individual who went by the screen name
Rose. Following the conversation, I received messages from multiple
women on Discord and Twitter who had been in contact with Destiny
and who told me that Destiny had shared with them content depicting
myself as well as others. Excuse me. Sometime after the November
29th, 2024 leaks, I discovered that Destiny deleted messages
between himself and I related to the forgoing. So, he absolutely
knows who this is. And I can't imagine he doesn't know who the
other one is. Maybe he doesn't know who the other one is. As
Destiny said before that he keeps like an Excel document of his
partners or am I making that up? You're not making that up. That
is accurate. He has said that. Yes. Is it appropriate to include
testimony at other videos Destiny sent that were not related
to directly to Pixie? Uh, so Destiny will say no. But there is
something to say like hey this pattern this this exact pattern
of behavior does relate like quite closely and and could be used
like basically because the timelines match up so closely. It
seems like it's indication like if you had a pattern of somebody
robbing banks in the exact time frame that you're accusing them
of robbing a bank. I do believe that is relevant information.
Now it will be relevant like contextual information but is it
proof? I don't know. Right. So it's like is it will depend on
whether or not it p it pertains directly to the exact crime being
alleged. I think right and that there could be a pattern of behavior
there around that crime. I just generally proving that they're
like a person or something. I think that can be taken away but
I do believe there are arguments there's there's an exact name
for it. Major Windy always sends it to me whenever I there's
a there's a name for this kind of evidence and it there is a
high bar to having it included. Like it needs to be directly
related. It needs to be like kind of directly related to one
of the charges and show like there is some pattern going on there.
These will be like supporting pieces of evidence to subpoena
Google and Discord and to try to get like yeah copies of his
messages and stuff. We can only hope. Anyway, so that was all
to say that's u that's basically he's saying I don't know who
these people are. Seems a little absurd to me. I think he should
probably have a list. I would imagine you'd have a list of the
people you shared those documents to that you should be able
to go check some permissions and stuff. But yeah, we know it's
4 to playing the uh ye old the early onset Alzheimer's card.
I don't know who these people are. No clue. The suggesting to
the court that he doesn't know who these people are based off
of the information they gave in these statements help his case
makes him sound super degenerate. Um I don't believe it should
hurt his case. I don't think so. It does make him sound insanely
degenerate, but yeah, I don't think it necessarily hurts his
case. Sure. Okay. Lagono, I don't remember anything. So EP Okay.
Uh, so we went from this guy. Now I think the other things attached
here are copies of the emails. And I think I'm referenced here,
which is super cool. Love to get love to get a shout out once
in a while, you know. Always cool to get a shout out. Can't they
just show Destiny joking about wanting your docs and you and
Que and shut that down immediately? Uh, Nyrosocks, you would
be shocked. Okay, but but I will talk about a couple things here
because we need to go through these emails real quick and these
emails are going to include some interesting stuff. So this is
uh this is document A. This is exhibit A from here or the copies
of the emails. This is going to be what they wanted to show to
show that he was asking for the identities of the people. So
sorry is A2. Thank you. And then May 2nd. Good afternoon Andrew.
I hope you're doing well. Pursuant to local rule 7.1A 3, we are
meeting and conferring. We're meeting and conferring on the following
motions. Motion to file under seal certain documents and it proposed
order. Motion for leave to exceed uh page limit on reply memorandum.
These documents to be filed under seal are certain statements
by witnesses which purpose is to keep their names out of the
public. You and your client will know their identities. I apologize
for not reaching out before it's been an intense week. Please
let me know and thank you. So, this is 7:59 p.m. Let me look
back. I just want to see here when did they file these because
they should have been on what? May 3rd. May 2nd. May 3rd. So,
it's like these are even stretching into May 3rd here. Okay.
This email says May 2nd. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I think basically
it's like slightly after May 2nd is when Oh, maybe not. Okay.
No, it's May 3rd. All right. Sorry. I was just I was a little
confused. The deadline for them replying, I believe, was May
3rd. Was it May 2nd? Hold on. Hold on. Let me Let me make sure
I know here. Ah, whatever. It's not It's not a big deal. Basically,
I think Andrew Brettler accused them of not making the deadline
because they were filing late into the night. Seems like they
had issues with things. It's midnight. It's fine. A
uh Okay. Um, I think basically it was that it wasn't before midnight,
but it it doesn't really matter. I I would assume like, hey,
we literally it's like 12:03 when these got filed. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Sorry, but I think it's like it's 12:03 when they get filed,
right? Did Destiny ever actually get JTO's docs info? Well, he
thinks so. He says he published it and he says it's correct.
So, he literally himself purported to have published it. So,
anyway, Mr. Bretler, note that this is May 5th. I wonder why
we didn't get the emails in between here. Mr. Mr. Breler, note
that local
54B1 provides inrelevant part if prior to the issuance of a ruling
on the motion to file under seal. The moving party elects or
is required to publicly file a pleading motion memorandum. This
is the one that esports Batman linked or other document that
attaches or reveals the content of the proposed sealed material.
Then the moving party must redact from the public filing all
content that is subject to the motion to file under seal of a
ruling on a motion to the moving party elects or elects or is
required publicly. So I I'm guessing this is meant to be like
hey Alex or is required publicly to file. I'm guessing the moving
party here if you're if basically if there's a motion to file
under seal and then it says the moving party. So I don't think
that precludes the idea that you would file a motion to file
under seal you would you'd say hey we're filing under seal and
then you would be the moving party if you're filing additional
documents. Right? But it's saying that even if the other side
wanted to file the documents themselves if there is a pending
motion to seal you need to redact the things from that motion
to seal until there is a ruling. Right. I think that is what
this law is saying. It's meant to cover both sides. I believe
esports Batman, you're listening to me. You tell me if you think
otherwise. Okay. So, publicly file a pleading motion memorandum
or other documents that attaches or reveals the content of the
proposed sealed uh material. Then the moving party must redact
from public filing all content that is subject to the motion
to file under seal. Plaintiff elected to attach the declarations
to the reply and file a simultaneously simultaneous motion to
file under seal. Defendant has no right to receive the unredacted
documents at this time. It would be highly negligent if we were
to provide to your client the unredacted documents without the
protection of their identities by the court in light of your
client's public statements over the weekend maligning these declarants.
Uh, these weren't over the weekend, but sure. Uh, your client
has also threatened physical harm to Oh, sorry. Over these declarants,
maligning these declarants. Oh, uh, this is Abby. This is talking
about Abby. So, he literally was talking about Abby over the
weekend. Over the weekend. Yeah. Yeah. Okay, cool. Individual.
Um,
your client also threatened physical harm to other individuals
that have spoken out against him and in support of the plaintiff.
For Jtock and Queen, I them if I could, I'd show up to their
house and do it. I do want someone to Jay-to though or Lav or
Mr. Girl or Queen. All those people can go die.
You wouldn't do you are a pathetic loser.
Yeah, he wouldn't. He's trying to get somebody else. that just
the mental image of him trying to like punch someone and just
flailing around like a [__] is just uh yeah it is
funny. Okay. It's sad. Sure. It is. It is. It is. Damn. That
don't sound so cute on paper. No, it doesn't. And it's I don't
know how. So, this gets replied to. I wonder if there's any comment
on this at all. Moreover, you have the full
completely. I just going to like gloss over that. Moreover, you
have the full unredacted substantive content of the declarations.
The only redacted portions are those that would reveal the identities
of these declarants. There can be no legitimate urgency for you
or your client to know the witness's legal identities. That does
not alter the facts or your ability to defend your client in
these proceedings. Um, yeah, I would say that is almost certainly
true. I do think there's a constitutional right to face your
accuser and these people are like giving testimony in this case.
I don't know. Like obviously they can't be these people can't,
you know, file without their identities, but I do think it's
fine to hide their identities. I think what they're looking for
here is a confirmation from the judge like, hey, if there's any
leaking of these things, like this is insane, right? Like this
guy's leaked a whole bunch of information already. We need you
to like be on top of this, okay? There can be no legit. Oh yeah,
sure. Sure. For these and other additional reasons, we will not
be providing the underdacted documents unless they're under seal.
We consider our meet and confer efforts to have been exhausted.
Uh, thank you to 69 Allen Ders 69 Allen 420 Dersowitz for the
gifted sub. It was over on Twitch. Thank you very much. Okay,
so then 2:47 p.m. When does this come through? 153. So this is
quoting another thing but repeated requests. You failed failed
and or refused. Is this all indirect? Maybe it is. You have failed
and or refused to provide us with unredacted copies of declarations
you improperly filed with your reply papers on Friday. Your continued
failure and/or refusal to provide the requested documents violates
local rule 5.4. You do not immediately provide us with the unredacted
filings. We will so advise the court and seek appropriate remedies
including but not limited to striking the pleadings relying on
the unauthorized declarations and the imposition of judicial
sanctions against you and your client. I mean you literally it
says in it's crazy that in local rule 5.4 I believe it says explicitly
that failing to meet these standards like the sanctions do not
include uh sanctions against the client at all. Like this wouldn't
harm Pixie's case. This wouldn't harm Pixie in any way. It would
be basically only her lawyers. If they if they were to say this
was against the rules, it only her lawyers who would be in trouble,
right? And if the court doesn't grant your emotion, their identities
remain anonymous. Yeah, that would be the point. Yes. That like,
hey, we want to file like, okay, so here's the thing. Pixie's
team asked me to sign an affidavit for them, right? That Desi
had doxed me and threatened to kill me and all this. And I was
like, oh yeah, sure. As long as you can hide my identity. this
guy's clearly like calling for my death on the internet. I don't
want to give my identity away in any way. Like that, right? Um
and they were like, "Okay, well, we have to like file under sea
or whatever and blah blah blah blah blah." They basically said
like, "We can protect it." And I was like, "Um, you know what?
I'm going to sit back a little bit and I think you guys have
lots of time before trial and I'll I'll chill." But that's exactly
why cuz they're trying to say like, "Hey, if if the judge decides
not to file this under seal," which she spoke to her lawyers.
I had a meeting I was going to like I made a statement to them,
but then they were like, "Hey, we need your identity. We need
like your name." And I'm like, I'm not giving you that until
I know you can file it like privately. I've been covering all
of the stuff for this case. I see all this getting filed publicly,
right? Not necessarily Destiny. I don't trust this at all. This
guy is scum. This guy is actually scum. The Breler guy. Oh, definitely.
Yeah. I basically I mean I would want basically confirmation
that, you know, this guy would be destroying his reputation if
my identity got released, right? So I was like, "Hey, I'll chill.
I still might do it at some point. Um, but I just like I literally
I'm like this guy's literally calling for my death on the internet.
Why would I expose my identity? There's no way I'm going to do
that. That's crazy, right? That's crazy. Uh, so we'll see if
this cuz basically they're trying to say no, no, no. None of
this should be able to be filed under seal. No, no, no. If if
if the court overturns this chance to file under seal, then their
identities should shouldn't be anonymous, right? So anyway, uh
to be clear, because of your client's statements related to Jane
Doe and any potential witnesses, we had to file these under seal.
Once the court rules on the motion, we will proceed accordingly.
If the court grants the motion, you will know their identities.
Thank you. Okay. Yeah. Honestly, I would be fine. I would be
fine if um if there's like a a motion or sorry, a a ruling that
is filed under seal, I'd be fine with that. Okay. Without the
court ruling on your motion to seal, you filed redacted declarations.
Please send me the unredacted versions. in his belated meet and
confer email to me. Your co-consel represented the documents
to be filed under seal are certain statements by witnesses which
which whose purpose I think it's got to be whose purpose is to
keep their names out of the public. You and your client will
know their identities. We do not. Please provide that information.
Thank you. So he asked for it. Upon the ruling of the court on
our motion to file the unredacted exhibits under seal docket
48, we will proceed to file the unacted versions with the court
at which point you can access them. I would appreciate a response
to my email dated April 28th regarding the Discord subpoena.
So, it seems like they just go back and forth. It's they're just
being asked, right? So, she's like, "Yeah, um, literally the
court will give us a way to file under seal and it will be accessible
to you. Do not do not ask me for this stuff. Also, you've not
responded to my about the Discord subpoena from April 28th."
And he responds, "Please provide us with the unre unreacted unreacted
copies of your filings immediately. Good evening. We have a lot
of trouble uploading some of the exhibits. We tried for a couple
hours without success with some of them. Uh, attached is the
full blank blank blank the full attached is the full set of exhibits
to plaintiff's Jane Doe declaration that will be eventually be
uploaded. We apologize for the inconvenience and we will try
to solve the issue over the weekend as soon as we get some guidance
from Pacer. Thank you. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. So, how long will
it take for them to hear back from the judge on the decision
of whether stuff will be under seal or not? Anyone know that?
I literally have no idea. second here. Any legally people listening?
Uh, I don't know, but you continue that conversation for a second,
Kelly. Okay. I was hoping someone might Oh, he thought Batman
said no idea. I was just wondering what kind of a time frame
that usually is. Depends on how busy the judge is. So, they did
do they mostly have to like stop until the judge is like, "Yo,
yeah, or no." Well, the judge will have to Yeah, the judge will
have to make a ruling. I don't think there's any more um motions
that can be filed. I think there's now going to be a judge that
will make a ruling. So, I guess it will depend. I also don't
know because they filed these things under their um under their
preliminary injunction. I don't know if they need to refile these
or amend their their um their existing like complaints. I actually
have no idea how that's going to work exactly. We'll see. Interesting.
We will see. We will see. Yeah. Um will that stop like the back
and forth until like I don't know how long because like the the
dates they set were like sometime next year, right, for all of
this to like finally go ahead or whatever. I don't know how much
they have to like do like any ideas, guys. I don't know what
this shit's like. It's funny because they always seem like the
time is running out of or whatever, but I'm like this this it's
going to be ages in the future. Why is time running out? Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Anyway, the end of the year for discovery to be completed.
Okay. It's ages then. Why they always seem like they're in a
rush? Come Jesus. that this is already granted by the judge.
Uh, no, I don't think so. So, you're probably looking at a proposed
motion. Yeah, proposed order. This is basically they're saying,
"Hey, this is what we think it should look like if you want to
sign it." They literally give like a basically something for
the judge to sign. This is what we think it should look like.
You could sign this directly. That is a proposed order. It's
not actually binding in any way. Okay. Uh, I don't know how much
there else there is here. There's some other stuff here that
is kind of annoying, I guess. Um,
I can't talk about it on stream, but uh, yeah, like I said, basically
I feel like the as soon as as soon as this motion to seal is
granted under this like proposed thing, uh, I would definitely
file like an affidavit or something with uh, this team as long
as I know the the court's going to actually protect my identity.
But I until then, until I I feel like I'm confident that uh,
it's not going to be used maliciously against me, I'm chilling.
Chilling. You mean something just happened or something you spoke
about before? Oh, I mean like it's some older thing. Uh, hold
on. I'll I'll message you about it. Okay.